we goofed that was the admission
essentially from the center for disease
control director michelle belinsky when
she called for an overhaul of the agency
saying that in response to coven 19 the
cdc did not meet many expectations of
the american public she didn't get into
specifics about what they botched and
when it could have something to do with
don't wear masks do wear masks get one
shot get 50 shots anyway whatever the
confusion they're trying to clarify it
now with a complete revamp of the agency
who's affected and what's affected right
now with dr robert redfield of course
the former cdc director under donald
trump kind enough to join us doctor good
to see you
good to see you neil thanks for having
me um what is she saying doctor and and
is she right uh
did the cdc botch it
well neil i think at the heart of this
is when they really tell talk about a
reset
is
what the primary role of cdc is is it an
academic institution
or is it a public health response agency
and when it started back 75 years ago
working with the defense department to
work on malaria it was a public health
response agency and what i think it's
dwarfed into
over the 75 years is to have more of a
culture of an academic institution and i
think at the heart of this report and
and what
the director has commented on is it's
really time for cdc to look in the
mirror
kind of see what it's become and ask the
question
is it is its culture
and structure optimized as a public
health response agency
or is it optimized
as an academic institution and i think
that's the heart of it so i think it's
an important first step it's going to be
a long journey to try to change the
culture of the agency and really make it
so it can be
a public health response okay you might
be right on the agency you're so
brilliant doctor you lost me with that
but but i i do want to understand i want
to get the brass tacks on this
is it just the guidance that was given
was wrong and then if we can get into
the specifics of that uh wearing masks
it was said originally bad idea not
necessary
then everybody wear masks uh is it on
lockdown and and and and keeping people
home uh that was advisable in the
beginning was that a mistake and then
for future pandemics is the signal that
those kind of things will not happen in
the future
well clearly the mandates and the
lockdowns and the closing of the schools
to virtual learning all of that was a
was a public health mistake there's no
question but what if everyone had gone
about their normal roles at the time
doctrine gone back to work i'm back in
crowded situations you don't think that
would have at some level made things
even worse or in retrospect you say no
it wouldn't now remember that's
pre-vaccine i think if
yeah i think you know clearly uh my view
was that we take a pause evaluate how to
do things in a safe and responsible way
but shutting down the schools
was much greater public health harm to
the kids than keeping the schools open
uh so just to be fair doctors i'm sorry
to keep jumping on you brutally but i uh
that's an important distinction you
would have not
done the school shutdown thing but you
would have embraced as the trump
administration did initially with some
reluctance this idea of everyone dialing
things back maybe you know doing their
jobs from their homes uh just not
extending that to keeping our kids out
of school
yeah i would have been a very select on
trying to look at each activity how to
do it in safe responsibility and
responsible for example in the
restaurant business i would have you
know stopped loud music and people
standing around bars but i would have
had people still be able to go into
restaurants
i think there was a mistake in those
regards but i think at the heart of it
neil and this is what i was trying to
get at cdc has a tendency to come up
with information
once they have all the data it's all
wrapped up in a bow it's perfect it's
ready for publication in the scientific
journal and what public health response
agencies have to do is take information
in real time and try to make real-time
recommendations and then modify those
recommendations as the data evolves but
i always give the example of my first
briefing that i had a cdc director
on the opioid deaths it was a week or so
after i was director and when i finished
the briefing i asked the cdc experts
what the data was through and they told
me it was through march of 2015 and i
said but it's april 2018
and they were explaining to me the
complexities of getting data and i was
explaining to them that doesn't help me
to launch a public health response based
on data that's three years old i think
that's at the heart of it i think that's
the heart of what we're talking about
that does make sense i do wonder no
matter what the changes are doctor going
forward
is it your belief
that vaccines were good that getting so
many americans i believe now up to 8 out
of 10 vaccinated was good
i think it's critical neil i you know i
think we've talked about this before
vaccines are the most important gift to
science to modern medicine
they do work the problem with the covet
vaccine is people need to think of it
more like a medicine
than a vaccine in other words a vaccine
you take once and you're done the covet
vaccine only works for a period of time
originally wuhan strain about eight to
twelve months the uk strain maybe six to
eight months the delta strain four to
say five to six months the omicron
strain four four months now the omicron
uh five four five probably three months
and that shouldn't surprise us because
natural infection if i get infected with
omicron five the immunity that i get
from that will only protect me for about
for about three to four months
well said doctor very good singing dr
robert redfeld the former cbc director
great to see you same here under
president trump